[Music]
all right let's be honest here
if we were kids and we're going to
school these days
and we're in covet times would you be
loving
homeschooling or would you be dying to
go back
you would like home school yeah dude i
did home school man
yeah wait wait did you say you like a
kid though as like a baby
all of a sudden he's a baby i think i
hated school since i was a kid
but what about seeing her friends there
i saw my friends other ways
like after school i would go outside and
play yeah like as soon as the
everyone was out of school like i would
have sick days right and then i would go
out would it what if like your parent
and then their parent were like
no kovid yeah can't see each other see i
don't know about that because i never
did that
but in eighth grade i did homeschool and
it was the funnest [ __ ] ever
cause i got to go online and jack off
whenever the [ __ ] i wanted
and going to class again mom don't come
in
are you so stupid and they didn't have
online school bro like back then it was
[ __ ] mail order
all the [ __ ] that they gave you was so
you
pack it yeah you get packets you do your
homework
so you could get the answers online or
go to the library and [ __ ] you could get
all the answers
and how they gonna check when you have a
test like they can't check that [ __ ]
they just give you a packet
and my mom's not watching me i just
email i mean um i just send the mail
back
and that's it and that eventually i just
stopped doing my work
that was my continuation school but i
had to go to physical school to do that
continuation oh is that in high school
yeah yeah so because the reason that i
spent a whole year in mexico in the
middle of my high school
mexico um then you have to make up your
credits
i had to make up the credits i had to go
to continuation school and that's what
it was it was just they would hand you
packets
and but you had to actually physically
go and do the packets
at the school yeah i remember that that
was
the latter half of my high school i do
feel like we're gonna have like this
generation
it's probably gonna be the dumbest kids
we've ever had yeah why
just because all the homeschooling
there's like internet issues like
teachers are freaking out
it's just like a lot of kids need that
in person
if you're a smart studious kid well
maybe like i guess the
education gap will be the biggest gap
because if you're a smart studious kid
you could study on your own and you
sometimes the teacher slows you down
so if you have a smart kid like that um
you're probably killing it yeah but then
there's also the regular people that
need like
the teacher to like you know drill it
into them i see and i think majority of
kids are like that and they're probably
not getting education where does the
kid that is like when he's in class he's
too social
and he's talking to everyone gets
distracted gets bad grades
are you talking about me talk about
isaac actually and well he doesn't he
never got bad grades but like
he was not doing as good as he's doing
now because he doesn't have those
distractions he's actually liking
like for in terms of his school school
like
education his school performance he's
loving
um being homeschooled so i think some
kids are probably killing it like that
the social
aspect social aspect is what's getting
him depressed
he needs to learn how to make friends
well he can he's in a brand new school
and they are
they're only online like it's it's
really bad no kids are playing in the
streets
yeah brand new schools people don't play
on the streets no more you don't
no at all like yeah you can't make it
they're not down to like you can't be
like hey anybody want to hang out after
no one's down to hang out no one's who's
gonna stand there
remember how awkward you were just being
regular hell of friends in seventh grade
yeah but imagine being in a brand new
school not knowing anyone
only seeing people via your computer
screen having
zero social interaction only whenever
the teacher pairs you up with someone
what if he hangs out at that fosters
freeze
yeah i don't know man there's a lot of
kids out there
teaching how to make friends that's
where all the cool kids hang out foster
freeze
yeah but it was it sucked too because
they were i don't know about
now but like in the beginning the parks
were closed he couldn't even socialize
with anyone
at all like it was it's just been bad i
don't know damn that is rough
crazy but the reason why i said i would
love it though is
because i always like sleeping in that's
true
you could you could roll out of bed and
then and hop on
and don't turn your camera on and like
just be listening and like okay
i think it's easier to cheat yeah
because as i went
through my my high school to college
career that's when when i was in college
that's when everything would be online
and i was like dude
it's too easy yeah it's too easy i
wouldn't even show up to class and i
would just be like
damn dude i had i had i had a uh
what do you call it morals
i think in college it was like i want to
prove to myself
that i'm actually not a dumb buck and if
i never challenged myself i don't know i
was too [ __ ] honorable dude
i hate myself now you're making me feel
like a piece of [ __ ] no because
because in high school and all that's
the next time i don't even i don't even
do any work or nothing i'll make you
feel good
and i was like if i never even try how
would i even know
if i can [ __ ] stand up in this world
against like whatever right
because like i'm just avoiding [ __ ] so
then i went to college and i'm like
alright [ __ ]
i'm gonna [ __ ] win at this game hey
hey you know what i
had a very different attitude going in i
was like these [ __ ] are robbing
us they're taking our [ __ ] money like
these classes i'm in
i don't even learn [ __ ] because why are
you still in it i know but that was the
thing it was like you know
i'm supposed to do it you gotta play
ball you know i mean you gotta play ball
most of the classes i did not like
because they just seemed like
the teachers would phone it in i had
this one uh professor he would brag
about how he was tenured and he would
have
powerpoint sheets and he'd sit at the
desk and just
read from the powerpoint sheet oh my god
not even post them up not even post them
up or send it out
and then be like yeah the test is on
what i said okay
lazy are you [ __ ] kidding me so he's
doing it just because he's forced to do
it but he doesn't even want it i don't
even know what's going through his
[ __ ] head well that seems to be the
case in san francisco
because now san francisco is in such a
dire situation where
the city itself is suing
the school district to san francisco wow
how are you going to order 2 year olds
it's never happened before like ever in
all of the us
so the city is suing its own school
district because the school district
refuses
to open up the schools and well
granted we are in a pandemic so there
are reasons why they're not opening it
up but
the city doesn't feel that the school
district even has a plan
and the idea is that you're planning to
plan but there's no actual plan
they're like you're being a lazy [ __ ]
we're gonna sue you and that was the
complaint too when uh the pandemic first
happened
i coached a lot of kids and their
parents and they were telling me that
like
yeah we don't know what's gonna happen
even for for the first like six months
they're like
we're still just kind of like yeah like
they don't really
the teacher's like sleeping in too and
they're like i like rolling out of bed
and just teaching
this is tight so what are the bathrooms
does it make sense to me is like
um the school system gets paid by like
taxpayers homeowners whatever
right and then like if they're being
lazy with the money
aren't they doing a shitty ass job like
if they don't have a plan if they don't
know
like any system or structure it starts
from the top right exactly because it's
not really the teacher's fault
yeah it's the top yeah yeah yeah and
then
like they get to keep their fat ass
salary while nothing happens
like that's some lazy ass [ __ ] dude yeah
yeah cause even isaac's school like
they're
constantly updating us and communicating
with plans and like
oh by this date this is when we're
projecting to have like from
kindergarten to second grade kids come
in and and then like they're constantly
updating us like when we had the new
stay-at-home order they're like well we
wanted to get kids back in by january
something
but then we had to like move it or
whatever they're constantly
communicating that's really good
is that a public school or that it's a
public school yeah that's crazy because
i hear i have some teacher friends and
stuff like i stayed friends with some of
my teachers from high school and stuff
and listening to them like
it's like they're like yeah they just
kind of handed us their light it was
just like well take your plan
and make it online it was just like
that's not like
apples and oranges they have to figure
out how to use all these new programs
that like nobody ever taught them how to
use they have to learn how to like
keep their kids interested you know it's
hard enough like if i'm here like
yelling
like you know talking to you in person
much less like all these kids tuned in
like virtually gaming on the other
screen exactly
i can pull out my phone while i'm on my
laptop and i can just be playing
games like this while i'm staring into
the [ __ ] screen like why wouldn't you
do that if you're exactly
or you could just record like a 30
minute reaction
view like every time it's class just
play that
and then go back to sleep dude i was
reading an article some kid uh figured
out that he could just
title his name like on the zoom app or
whatever he
he wrote reconnecting dot dot dot and he
just sat there and he never had to say
anything or
interact with the class and he just sat
there waiting for the class to end
you know that the teacher or like how
does the teacher know he's he's there or
participating
or what well he has bad internet and you
can't really blame the kid for bad
internet it's kind of like that spectrum
dude
spectrum is the worst spectrum what
exactly
are they getting sued for do you know uh
they're getting sued
for let me see what what is the most
[ __ ] negligence yeah yeah [ __ ]
negligence screwing the next generation
yeah
all those actually so the argument is
like
the argument is like well there's data
being shown that
like through distance learning um
particularly black latino and asian
low-income students
are are not you know gaining ground in
their education as opposed to the white
counterparts that's like some data that
they were arguing
with you know and um and they're also
saying that
a lot of private schools are also open
like in san francisco private schools
are open
like in class teaching they're doing it
it's like they're doing it why are the
public schools why are they refusing to
make a plan to even approach this kind
of like end goal so like there doesn't
seem to be an end goal
and so that kind of goes back to what
bart was saying how like there's gonna
be a huge gap
of like yeah more kids that
had time and that that what do you call
it like they had a head start because
during the pandemic they had a better
education
versus like the poorer kids that had a
[ __ ] education well kind of like with
with even in the job economy like just
the economy businesses yeah
yeah yeah exactly small businesses are
shutting down they can't make ends meet
and then rich people are just getting
richer see like when we went to uh
hawaii because obviously they did
another lockdown in california
and all the small businesses were like
all right figure it out go ahead all the
restaurants especially
but in hawaii this they had a plan like
everything was open but it was under
strict regulations it was like
you can't be in a restaurant for more
than an hour and a half oh cool they
have contact tracing so you when you go
and eat
you have to fill out a form so if
somebody gets exposed the restaurant
will call you back and be like hey
no [ __ ] and they have they had a plan
for everything they had like you know
they had the dividers and they followed
through on that
that's amazing that they followed
through but but once again it starts
from the top
like they're i don't know that much
about their governor but in
contrast from hawaii to california it
just seemed like
newsome was like all right figure it out
go ahead just do your thing dude have
you seen the stats like
they put more um rules on la
and then we got the spike like how did
that even happen
really because everybody's just so
cooped up right it's like they're just
like [ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] it's kind of like with parenting
like the more you tighten the leash on
your crazy teenagers the more they're
gonna
rebel or maybe it could also just be the
illogical rules
yeah because it doesn't make sense uh
after 10 you got to go inside and then
there's all these memes with white
because after 10
virus goes to sleep or something all
right but all the hawaii rules it's
after 10 it does yeah it does it but
like all the hawaii rules everything
like makes logical sense so you're like
oh i'll follow that i get why i have to
write my name down because then if
there's a case you'll call me and i'll
go get checked well also hawaii has a
much more insular population like
they're literally on a [ __ ] island
with a tiny little population of people
so like i remember when it first started
happening they like cut off a lot of
flights like you couldn't come into
hawaii at all or if you did you had a
quarantine
for you had to quarantine for like a big
chunk of time i think it was like two
weeks
two weeks ten days and they would check
in on you because i had i knew some
people that had to go for
like some family stuff and then they
would check in and they had like
trackers on your phone to figure out if
you were actually where you are and they
would call in and check on you and be
like are you at the hotel because if
you're not we're going to find you yeah
and stuff like that so
they can control that a lot more and
then i know in california they were just
kind of like
oh yeah you should quarantine and then
when i came out
they were like 10-day quarantine
mandatory but yeah who's checking though
no one's no one's checking out i just
felt kind of like like insulted like no
one checked up on me
no one cares nobody cares dude no but
then also you have people like in the oc
who are [ __ ] protesting about wearing
masks
like how are how are how is california
gonna force anything when people are
like you're infringing on my rights
yeah no i agree that's the part that i
don't know about like you're like oh
yeah people just follow logical rules
it's like i don't know man
people are dumb people aren't dumb and
you can't there's people
on there it's just probably harder
because our population is like
the size of it's bigger than canada like
there's a lot like a country
yeah so you know we just have a lot of
people a lot of demographics and it
doesn't help that our own governor who
puts these rules out
and he says it with a smirk every single
time and then he does the exact
opposition yeah and then he goes home
and he goes and he eats at a restaurant
i hand some of that bastard that rap
hasn't heard
him though he runs me like american
psycho yeah
like he'll slit your throat you know
like you're handsome but it's wrong but
you're gonna do some crazy [ __ ]
you